what do you think people don't
understand fully about stress there's an
experiment in animals where a rat is
given the opportunity to run on a
treadmill rats and rodents of all kind
love running on treadmills there's
something rewarding about it for them
but in any event it lowers their blood
pressure it leads to Inc improvements in
a number of metrics that you expect and
you see the same thing in humans who run
on a treadmill or run Outdoors or Swim
cardiovascular exercise and I love to
talk about an experiment where they took
two different cages with animals one is
running voluntarily but then that
running wheel is Tethered to a running
wheel in another cage that encloses an
animal forces it to run every time the
other one runs so forced exercise versus
voluntary exercise and the takeaway is
very straightforward voluntary exercise
leads to all sorts of improvements in
health metrics resting heart rate blood
pressure blood glucose resting blood
glucose Etc the animal that's forced to
exercise you see the opposite so it's
not exercise per se it's something about
being forced to exercise is it causes
decrements in a number of Health metrics
and you see the same thing in humans